Good morning.
Thank you for coming to our session.
My name is Carmen Guerra, and it is my pleasure to both
moderate and speak at this session titled
HPV Vaccination and Self-Sampling for Cervical Cancer
Prevention and Early Detection Globally and
in Underserved Settings.
I would like to introduce you to today's speakers.
First, you will hear from Dr. Amy Kramer.
She is a senior investigator at the Intramural Research
program at the National Cancer Institute in the Division
of Cancer, Epidemiology and Genetics.
Her research focuses on the etiology and prevention of
HPV-driven cancers. She is the NCI
principal investigators on several prophylactic
HPV vaccine trials, including ESCUDO, a
randomized trial of one dose HPV vaccination.
And this is a research initiative of the Cancer Moonshot.
Next, I will have the pleasure to speak.
I am a general internist and epidemiologist by training, and a
professor of medicine and a professor of biostatistics
and epidemiology at the Perelman School of Medicine at the University of
Pennsylvania.
I also serve as the associate director for community outreach and
engagement at the Abramson Cancer Center, and I am
one of the site PIs for the National Cancer
Institute SHIP trial at the University of Pennsylvania.
And I will be speaking to you today about the exciting
results of this trial.
And lastly, we have Jane Montealegre, who is an associate
professor of behavioral science at the University of Texas
MD Anderson in Houston, Texas. She is a behavioral
epidemiologist in implementation science with research expertise
in the design, implementation, and evaluation of community and
health system-based interventions to increase delivery and
uptake of cancer prevention services,
particularly in safety net health settings.
Her research focuses on the prevention and detection of cervical and
other HPV-associated cancers. Dr.
Montealegre has conducted extensive research on
self-collection for HPV testing to improve access to
cervical cancer screening. And currently, she is the principal
investigator of several studies that evaluate the implementation and
effectiveness of
self-collection in safety net health settings and other
low-resource settings. So without further ado, I'd like to
invite our first speaker, Dr. Amy Kramer, to take the podium.
Thank you.
Hey.
Morning, everyone.
Hi, I'm Amy Kramer,
National Cancer Institute, and I'm going to talk to you today about
single-dose HPV vaccination.
And I have no financial relationships to disclose.
So just to go big picture in this session on global cervical cancer
prevention, we know that cervical cancer is the fourth most
common cancer in women, with over 600,000 new
cases annually.
As everyone here probably knows, HPV causes cervical cancer, as
well as cancer at multiple anatomic sites.
We'll talk about that a little bit more on the next slide.
But cervical cancer does make up 90% of the global
burden of these HPV-driven cancers, and
90% of the cervical cancer cases and
deaths are in lower resource settings.
So I was very excited to be included in this session today
because I think we really do need to keep eyes on how to
prevent cervical cancers, both in the United States, of course,
because there are settings in the US that still continue to have higher
rates of cervical cancer. But if we look at this global map, we
see the age-standardized incidence rates.
And in places in Latin America, Africa, Asia,
we see cervical cancer rates that are simply no longer
acceptable.
Since we're in a meeting in the United States, I thought I would show the
epidemiology of HPV-driven cancers here.
And here it's actually quite interesting because we do see a greater burden
of HPV attributable oropharynx cancer rather than
cervical cancer in the United States.
So this figure from the CDC shows the
estimated number of cancer cases
attributed to HPV by sex, cancer type, and HPV type.
So first we see in females, cervical cancer is still the most common cancer in the
US, with around 8,100 cases caused
by HPV 16 and 18, and then you see the other type
attribution. Note, of course, cervical cancer we believe is
completely attributable to HPV infection, unlike the other
cancers where there's this mixed etiology with cancers due to
HPV as well as not due to HPV. We see in the
males, however, this very large burden, on the relative
scale, of oropharynx cancers, where it's actually
dwarfing the number of cervical cancers.
And that's because in the United States, cervical cancer screening, while
not efficient, has been effective at controlling cervical
cancer.
So let's talk about prophylactic HPV vaccines, because really at this
point, I can think we can say strongly that prophylactic HPV
vaccination can prevent HPV-driven
cancers.
HPV vaccines are based on L1 virus-like particles, which
spontaneously assemble and mimic authentic virus capsid,
which induces high titer virion neutralizing antibodies.
These are both non-infectious and non-oncogenic.The
vaccines were initially approved in 2006 as a three-dose regimen
based on clinical trial data. The HPV vaccine does
prevent infections at all the anatomic sites where HPV causes
cancer. We do know this from clinical trial data, both
randomized and observational.
Real-world data shows a 90% reduction in cervical
pre-cancer and cancer among women vaccinated as adolescents.
Vaccination is easier than cervical cancer screening, though we have to acknowledge
that screening remains critically important because it brings
faster reductions in cervical cancer incidence.
So vaccination is an investment in our future.
Cervical cancer screening cuts out the prevalent disease in the
moment. There is no population-based screening for HPV-driven
cancers out beyond the cervix. So what's the problem?
I just told you all this great news. Like, it works. Let's celebrate.
Well, around 2020,
which was 15, 16, 17 years after the initial recommendations of
vaccination, the global uptake was 20%.
And if I stratify that weighted average, that 20%, and I
told you the global uptake in countries that have limited
resources, it would be closer to about 9%.
It just wasn't reaching where it needed to get to.
So I'm going to talk a little bit about my research today, as well as some of the
other research that's informed policy and important
discoveries. So my research is very focused.
How do we control then eliminate HPV-driven cancers?
I am all HPV all the time. I do primary prevention work with
HPV-driven cancers through prophylactic HPV vaccination
with a special focus on single-dose.
I also do etiology and secondary prevention work, but today, I'm going to focus on
HPV vaccination for cervical cancer prevention.
So prior to my time at the NCI,
before the HPV vaccines were licensed, there were two
pharmaceutical companies moving forward with large Phase III clinical trials,
and the NCI said, "You know what? There needs to be a publicly funded trial as
well. We need to have access to data to know what's going on." And so the NCI
launched a Costa Rica HPV vaccine trial, which we refer to as CVT,
in 2004. It was a pre-licensure trial
investigating the safety and the efficacy of three doses
of the bivalent HPV vaccine.
In 2004 and 2005, they enrolled nearly 7,500 women
between the ages of 18 and 25 years.
They were randomized to receive either three doses of a HepA vaccine as a
control vaccine or the Cervarix GSK bivalent vaccine.
Because these women were 18 to 25 years old, because this was in
a pre-licensure trial where we were evaluating safety and efficacy,
20% of participants received fewer than three doses.
Leading reasons for this, they were getting pregnant.
We didn't vaccinate during pregnancy.
They had a referral to colposcopy, so that put them on a different track.
So we then had a group of people who received one and two doses.
In 2011, we published our initial data.
We said four years after HPV vaccination, we had
non-randomized analysis that suggested that one dose
appeared to protect as well as three doses.
We were very excited with this, but it completely broke with vaccine
dogma. Vaccine dogma said that subunit vaccines,
so vaccines that are predicated on one part of the
virus, in this case, the virus capsid, requires
prime plus boost to induce protective immunity.
So we said, "Everyone, this is hypothesis-generating." It
was not received very well, and we got a lot of pushback.
We had to really commit to generating the data, and in fact, there was a
piece in "The New Yorker" this year that says, "Kramer was subjected to God knows
how much skepticism," said the Dame Margaret Stanley, who I
adore, of course. She counted herself among the
disbelievers back then. She said it was heresy for a
protein-based vaccine to work with only one dose.
So this is where I pause in my talk and I say, "Stay true to the
data." We have to just continue to let the data drive our course of
inquiry. So we kept going.
In 2013, we published our antibody data, and we showed
stable antibody responses for four years following one dose of
the vaccine, and we said, "Oh my gosh, it's durable." And then we
needed more data because, again, we still were meeting with such disbelief.
So we reached out to the industry
who had run these Phase III trials, and we said, "Can we work in your datasets?"
GSK said yes, and we reproduced similar single-dose
HPV vaccine efficacy results in their PATRICIA trial, and we said, "Oh my
goodness, it's consistent." So what happened next, and why was it needed?
We continued to generate data on single dose in this original trial, and I'm going
to share some of those data now. And we and others embark on
formal randomized clinical trials to evaluate one-dose HPV
vaccination.
So this is a cut of our data 11 years after
HPV vaccination in this non-randomized one-dose group,
and we're benchmarking our one-dose arm against the women who received three
doses. And so this is against HPV 16,
18 infections,
and the vaccine efficacy, as you can see, is quite the same.
So why isn't this enough? Why can't we just say, "Let's change policy.
Let's do one dose." Well, two points. One, non-randomized.
It's non-randomized. We did everything in the world to rule out selection bias, but
we can't overcome non-randomized.
And also, our one-dose group was small.
It had 112 people in it,
so it wasn't powered. We were limited just by the number of people who went off
schedule and got one dose. So we also did
antibody work in these people. This is the same group of people.
So on this figure, I'm showing you follow up to year
11.And then on a log scale, the HPV
16 antibody GMCs, and the data for HPV
18 looks the same.
Starting with the three-dose arm here in purple, what you see is this peak
here that starting kind of higher up, and then it goes into this plateau,
and the plateau keeps going. What has been really remarkably
surprising is that for the one dose, we see durable
protection that is also sustaining.
And in fact, if we look at the difference between the one-dose antibody
levels and the three dose, it's about four-fold.
Virology immunology, not my expertise, but if we look at the
experts in the room, especially John Schiller, who's sitting with us, he would
say, I think, that a four-fold difference in
antibodies is not usually a break point for where you see
protection and not protection. And in fact, in the efficacy
data I showed you in the previous slide, we're seeing robust efficacy no
matter what the antibody level is.
So this kind of gives us a little nugget of information where even though we
lack a correlate of protection, we do observe that lower antibody levels do
not equate to inferior protection. This is in the field.
We just wrapped up the 20-year visit,
and our 20-year results are actually expected towards the end of this year.
So that's quite exciting. So as I said,
we and others knew we needed more. We need formal randomized trial.
And so we launched two. We had ESCUDO, which is a formal non-inferiority
trial of one to two doses. And then we had PRISMA, which is
a one-dose efficacy trial in young adult women.
And I'm going to talk a little bit about both of those today after I check the
time.
Seems good. Okay. So ESCUDO. ESCUDO had co-primary
aims. The first one was the non-inferiority of one versus two doses in the
prevention of new cervical HPV 16/18
infections in girls who were 12 to 16
years. So this recruited 20,000
girls at enrollment were randomized to vaccine product.
We studied both the bivalent vaccine and the Merck nonavalent vaccine.
Six months later, they were randomized to a dosing schedule.
They either received a second dose of the same vaccine or a control vaccine if they
were a one-dose randomized arm.
We actively followed them over six-month intervals to collect cervical
cells, blood, and urine. And you can see this went out to
five years. A note that our girls aged into the cervical
sample self-collection at the age of 15.
Prior to that, we assume they were HPV negative.
So here are the results. We published these in December.
These are for the first co-primary aim, looking at the non-inferiority of
one versus two doses.
For this endpoint of incident, six-month persistent cervical HPV
16 infections and who were HPV naive during the
vaccination phase. So I'm going to walk you through this table.
I've had to learn quite a bit about non-inferiority trials.
Efficacy is much easier to consume.
This is the Cervarix arm and then the Gardasil 9 arm,
the one dose and the two dose. You see the number per arm,
the number of events in each arm, and then the cumulative event
rate, and a rate difference on an absolute scale.
You then see a P-value that's testing whether
this observed rate difference rules out a pre-specified
margin that maps to at least 80% efficacy.
So for the Cervarix arm, you see a very small rate
difference with a highly statistically significant P-value, which means
that we're observing here over 80% efficacy, which was the
non-inferiority margin of the trial.
When we go to Gardasil 9, again, for an endpoint of 16/18,
we again see a very small rate difference and a highly statistically significant
P-value, so we succeeded on co-primary aim one.
We additionally conducted an end-of-study survey to capture
data on unvaccinated women. We could not run this ethically in
our opinion as a randomized control trial against a zero-dose group because
these vaccines were already approved.
We really thought the question at hand was compared to the gold standard dosing
regimen, how does one dose compare?
But we did want that zero-dose information.
We enrolled a survey who
looked very similar in terms of age and region to the
randomized clinical group. We
captured their HPV infection status, and then we provided them HPV
vaccination.
With these data, we were able to compute HPV vaccine efficacy.
So here we're seeing against that unvaccinated survey efficacy
for one dose Cervarix, two doses Cervarix, one dose Gardasil 9, and two doses
Gardasil 9, and what you see is very,
very high protection for all four arms with no
differences.
We do have additional data that I'm not going to share today.
Looking at the other five carcinogenic types
in the nonavalent vaccine were looked at as a pre-specified aim.
We also saw no significant differences between one and two doses on
that. And if I refer you to the paper, we do everything
under the sun, every individual genotype, every composite endpoint, so
lots of information there, one million supplemental tables.
Here is one of our secondary aims, which is immunogenicity.
These data are not yet published.
They're under review right now. So our immunogenicity
data went out to three years. If we look at this legend, you see Cervarix
is blue, Gardasil 9 is red. If it's a solid
dot, it's a one dose and an open dot, it's two
doses. So the antibody patterns fell out kind of what you
would expect. Three years later, what you see is two
doses of Cervarix gives the highest, then two doses of Gardasil
9, then one dose of Cervarix, and one dose of Gardasil 9.
Similar for HPV 18.
And for all the types that are included in a vaccine
formulation, you see really robust antibody
patterns.So, as I had indicated,
several groups around the world started
launching single-dose trials. I would like to just touch on a couple of
them. I do put the references in the bottom right corner if
you want more information. Trials were launched in
Kenya, the KENCHI trial. This one is critically
important as it changed global policy.
It was randomized
women aged 15 to 20 with a three-year follow-up.
They looked at also the GSK vaccine and the nonavalent
vaccine and showed high vaccine efficacy
against HPV 16/18 for both vaccines.
Many of us were following the GSK vaccine and
the alum-adjuvanted vaccines because there was a real question when
we started these single-dose trials about,
the GSK vaccines have a different sort of
adjuvant that gives a higher antibody response.
We saw that in the previous immunogenicity slides, and so we had a real
question if that was going to be necessary to confer
protection with a single dose. And in fact, what we're seeing now is,
in fact, all the Merck vaccines that have an alum adjuvant, the
GSK vaccines that have a TLR
agonist adjuvant, are all giving similarly robust
results.
Tanzania launched an immunogenicity study.
High seropositivity for one dose.
And India also had a broken randomization
trial, like CVT, where we had these non-randomized women,
and they have a huge one-dose group of about 5,000
women. Follow-up time out is 12 years now, going
strong with follow-up. Not only are they showing high vaccine efficacy
against virologic endpoints, but they're also providing evidence against
histologic endpoints.
There do remain persistent gaps in knowledge.
I'm not here just to do all the sunshine.
I have to do the clouds, too.
We need to know how far up an age scale one dose can work.
Is it adult women? We have very little data on men,
though the a priori biological hypothesis is that it
will work well at mucosal sites in men.
We don't know about non-cervical sites, oral and anal.
And I showed you in the USA, oropharynx cancer is really important.
And new vaccine products are coming out. This is amazing.
It's exactly what a healthy vaccine market needs.
We see new products coming out of China and India.
We have optimistic data showing that one dose will work there, but we'll
need to continue to follow that as well.
I do want to wrap up with two more points.
One, we have another trial that I had mentioned, our PRISMA
trial. This is single-dose HPV vaccine protection among
adult women aged 18 to 30. So I shared some of the gaps that
are in the literature right now, and now I'm going to tell you a little bit about
what we're trying to do to work in some of those spaces.
What is the point of getting vaccination, thinking in these
resource-limited settings in women 18 to 30, where perhaps
standing up
screening has been an overwhelming challenge?
We hope to accelerate the potential impact of HPV
vaccination. So right now, if we vaccinate 12 to 16-year-olds or
9 to 15-year-olds, we are waiting decades to see the reduction in
cervical cancers, and we want to bring that forward in calendar time.
And so one of our approaches to doing that is to vaccinate
further up on age range. This could be considered like a catch-up,
programmatically a catch-up. We're not leaving it there forever.
It's a one-time thing. It's a band-aid while we wait for the
vaccinated cohorts to age into cancer-susceptible years.
We did an enrollment visit in 2022, over 5,000 women, and then
three months later, a vaccination visit.
At those two visits, we collect a cervical sample to rule out prevalent HPV
infection to form an ATP cohort. We then
randomize in a blinded fashion to one dose of the nonavalent, one dose of the
bivalent, and one dose of a control vaccine.
Our follow-up started at 12 months.
We then saw them every six months for three years.
Cervical HPV virologic endpoint is our primary endpoint,
but we do have anal and oral cell collections
to inform a secondary endpoint. So again, I told you persistent gaps in the
literature included, does one dose protect at these
non-cervical sites? The biologic hypothesis is yes,
it will, but we need data to inform that.
Very exciting news. Our results are expected in fall of this
year. We look to break them over the summer.
We're working really hard. We're tired.
Okay, just to wrap up, I told you in 2020, there was
20% global HPV vaccine uptake, and if
I stratified that by low and
high resource settings, it looked to be about 9%.
I pulled this map off the WHO HPV dashboard
about a month ago.
First on the left, I'd like to call your attention to the number of countries
that now have HPV vaccination in their national
immunization programs. I don't know the
numbers, so I can't add offhand, but it's a lot.
It's close to 150, and of those,
90 are providing one dose. So,
a one-dose recommendation. And that one-dose recommendation goes from nine to
20 and includes girls and boys.
If we look to the right of the slide, we can now see the global
uptake of one dose of HPV vaccination is at
63%.
And if I go into world regions,
you can look at Afro as example, is around
67%. You can look at the map where you can see
the different schedules that are being provided.
And so with that, I think we are at the beginning
of the end of cervical cancer.So that's my rainbow.
But I have to say, now is not the time to let up,
because we could say we're at the beginning of the end of cervical cancer
because HPV vaccination is being integrated to more and more
countries. But if we don't continue to push on this,
HPV vaccine uptake and screening when
possible will drive how fast we achieve
these goals. So again, high uptake is what is needed,
not just a map that shows a color that says a country's
doing it. It's really what is the uptake in country, and if you're able to
do more age bands or perhaps males, if you're able to add
screening, that is how we are going to achieve cervical cancer
control globally.
I'm always honored to present on behalf of a huge team at the
United States National Cancer Institute and in Costa Rica.
And as always, we extend our gratitude to the young women and girls of Costa
Rica who participate in these studies in an extraordinary display of
solidarity with all women and their families.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dr. Kramer, for that inspiring talk.
I still have chills from your vision of ending cervical
cancer. If it's okay with the audience, I would
love for us to humor us by requesting that all questions
be kept till the end.
And so we'll keep going with my talk next.
And so I'd like to begin with a few
disclosures and gratitude. Gratitude to AACR for
hosting us and asking us to speak today, in particular, Dr.
Electra Paskett, who's also in the audience and nominated that this
be a topic included in this year's program.
These are my disclosures. And importantly, I
just want to also say that what I'm about to talk about are my own
views, and I don't speak for the NCI, I don't speak
for my employer, the University of Pennsylvania, or the American Cancer
Society.
So, as we shift to screening,
one of the most impactful things that has ever come along to
cancer screening, as you all know, is the Pap test, which was
introduced back in 1941, and since then,
the rate of cervical cancer has fallen by over
70%.
And you can see here in this diagram below, however,
that despite the important gains, there has been
stable mortality rates over time since about the
2000s.
The second problem is the problem of persistent
disparities in cervical cancer. The
mortality is higher for US Black
populations, as well as American Indian, Alaskan Native
individuals compared to white. It's higher for rural
versus urban populations and for low-income populations.
In addition, there are global disparities in cervical cancer
screening. And here is a map showing some of
those disparities in cervical cancer mortality, with
the deepest green being the lowest rates of
cervical cancer per 100,000, and then the red
showing the highest rates of cervical cancer mortality.
And although we made great gains since the introduction of the Pap
smear and now making great gains with the vaccination,
cervical cancer, as you heard, remains the fourth most common cause of
cancer death for women worldwide. You saw in Dr.
Kramer's, the statistics in her slides.
And overall, the discrepancy in low-
middle-income countries and cervical cancer mortality
is over tenfold that of high-income countries.
So these observations and data call
for a new method forward.
In the US, one of the things that's contributing to those
stagnant rates of cervical cancer mortality, as you'll see in this
diagram on the left, is data from the
National Cancer Institute Cancer Trends report.
The percent of women who are 25 to 65 who are up to date with
cervical cancer screening was going up until just
about 2000, and it has since, in the red line, been
falling. And in this country, in the US, we have
about over 200,000 cervical pre-cancer
cases, 11,000 cervical cancer cases, and about
4,000 deaths. And when you look at that data, 30% of
those women with cervical
cancer are not screened per recommendations.
And over half of the cervical cancer cases, the women
have been under-screened. And we've read in the
literature all the many barriers that women face, which are listed
here, to undergoing cervical cancer screening.
And so a new approach is needed.
And one of those approaches that many people, including people
in this room, have been working on is HPV self-sampling,
which was first proposed back in the late 1990s, but first
appeared in PubMed in about
2000s. And I cut and pasted one of the articles that you
see here that was one of the first to be published in PubMed
comparing self-vaginal collection with
clinician collection. And those early studies were
very hopeful.
They found that because there was a high prevalence
of HPV exfoliated in the vaginal specimens,
that the sensitivity ended up being pretty similar
to compare to clinician collected,
and these articles advised that there's sufficient sensitivity to
warrant further investigation.
And they also noted a high level of acceptability, so high
that the Australian government felt they wanted to engage in this
national campaign that you see on the bottom right
to help women conduct this self-sampling as a way to
increase their screening rates.So fast forward,
however, since the 2000s, when all that data first
began to appear, more and more data and randomized
trials accumulated over time to the point where in
2025, the American Cancer Society changed its
guidelines for the first time to include HPV
self-sampling as a
primary strategy for screening for cervical cancer.
In the highlighted area of the abstract, you can see that primary
HPV screening through clinician-collected methods was still
preferred, but that HPV self-collection was also
acceptable.
And so with this appearance of HPV in the
national ACS guidelines, there was increasing
momentum to begin to develop
strategies to address cervical cancer using this methodology.
But the real change has come recently, mostly
from NCI, and I'm going to present
several slides that my dear colleague, Vic
Sorhaz Rabude, has been kind enough to share
with me, and I'm sharing with you, as well as the most recent
results from the SHIP trial. He unfortunately couldn't be here.
He's out of the country at the moment, but he has
been the force behind the SHIP trial, and
I'm really grateful for him entrusting me to present this important
data today.
So one of the things that Vic and Phil Castle and their team
did was to
commission and conduct these meta-analyses that you see
here and develop the data
to propose what became the SHIP trial and the
bigger
Last Mile initiative at the NCI. So when they looked at
the data and pooled the data together through these meta-analyses, what
they discovered was that the vaginal self-collected samples using
PCR-based testing have higher sensitivity
compared to cytology. They have comparable sensitivity
compared to clinician-collected samples, and that there was high agreement
between self and clinician collection.
However, the studies were limited because many of
them had been done under...
The studies were not under controlled conditions, and some of the
methodologies varied for devices, varied
transportation varied, and the processing varied.
And overall, even though the data was encouraging, it was not
adequately rigorous for an FDA
approval.
And so that gave birth to the NCI Cervical
Cancer Last Mile initiative. The goal of this initiative was to
overcome barriers to the lack of FDA approval for self-collection
approaches, and that they would take the approach of
engaging both public and private sectors and
stakeholders to facilitate the regulatory approvals.
And the outcome would be to assess whether there was increased screening access.
And ultimately, does it reduce cervical cancer incidence,
especially in the underserved populations and high-burden
populations?
The key activities for the initiative
would be threefold: facilitating discussions for regulatory
approvals, then the design and conduct, and
implementation of the SHIP trial, the self-collection for HPV
testing to improve cervical cancer prevention, and ultimately
dissemination of the evidence on self-collection to
inform and change practice.
And the outcomes of the SHIP trial, as you can see here,
would focus predominantly on three things: accuracy,
as well as the usability and acceptability of
HPV self-sampling. Accuracy would be measured through
the positive and negative percent agreement between
self-collection and clinician collection, and the
usability and acceptability through patient
questionnaires administered by the teams involved.
And the NCI SHIP trial design is a platform trial,
which, as you can see here, it's a trial design that
evaluates multiple medical strategies, or products, or
treatments for a single disease or a single
condition simultaneously. And
the trial is designed in a way that the
different lanes can occur at different times.
And the SHIP trial currently is evaluating four
designs or sub protocols. It's a parallel
design, as you can see here, so they're occurring at the same time.
And the NCI is acting as the independent sponsor,
not the industry partners. And you can see those industry partners
here. And the aim, again, was to evaluate multiple
self-collection device assay combinations, comparing
those to clinician collection, again, to inform the
regulatory approvals.
And the public-private partnership you can see in this slide
involves many entities. It certainly involves the National Cancer
Institute, first and foremost, that has been
doing the most impactful HPV
research and continues to do so, as you heard from Amy's talk.
But also the FDA, the industry partners that you see
here, and then a coordinating center
at the Frederick National Laboratory for Cancer
Research,
called LEIDOS. And then it would engage the clinical
sites, and 25 clinical sites were
enrolled, and they were engaged as
subcontractors by the coordinating center
to enroll patients on the SHIP trial.
And so this is the brilliance of the
public-private partnership that ended up being an incredibly
effective strategy.These are the 24
partners that have been actively involved enrolling
patients on the SHIP trial. I mentioned I was from the University of
Pennsylvania and representing that enrollment site.
And then
I'm going to now begin to share the most up-to-date data on
that trial.
So first, as of April 10th, that trial
enrolled 2,088 participants
across the four sub protocols at the 24
active clinical sites that encompass 21
U.S. states and territories in the SHIP Trial Network.
And as you saw, the participation includes three U.S.
companies, BD, Roche, and Abbott, with
each having licensed primary HPV screening assays as
well as self-collection devices.
And you can see the four sub protocols here, as
well as their assay, their NCT numbers, and then the
status of enrollment. The first row, BD, has
completed its enrollments with 554 patients,
and the status of their FDA approval is that they
received approval. And that was the late-breaking news
that I'll talk more about shortly.
Whereas the Roche sub protocols have submitted their
FDA review applications after completion of enrollment,
and then the Abbott enrollment is still underway.
It's almost hit its target.
And they should be able to also submit their FDA
application for approval in the coming weeks to months.
This is the cumulative enrollment through March
20th. I already mentioned 2,088
patients total had enrolled as of April 10th.
This is taken a snapshot right before that, so the enrollment is just
slightly under 2,000. But you can see from this that the
overall cadence enrolled 32 patients per week out of the
64 open weeks, about 130 per month.
And so, for the first protocol, I'm just delighted and
honored to share the results. Again,
I'm presenting for the NCI, specifically for Dr.
Sahasrabudhe and Phil Castle and their team.
And some of this data has not been shared publicly before, so I do ask that you
do not post, and the slides will have a do not post
sign. So first, this is the SO1 protocol, the
BD protocol, and this is the demographics for
the 495 patients that completed all aspects of the
study. And you can see the demographics in the pie chart, but also in the table in
the middle. And importantly, what you can see is
that the Hispanic population represented about
23.6 of the trial enrollees, Black and African
American population, 37.6%. We know that these are
populations that have an increased burden of cervical cancer, and
so it was a tremendous achievement to achieve enrollment
in these proportions for that population.
On the right, you can see the age categories.
And to summarize, a little over half of the
population was within the ages of 30 to 49,
and you can see the other
age categories. And a little bit about their medical history, as you
can see, about 42% had at
least one HPV vaccine.
About 3.8% had HIV
seropositive status. And the median number of
pregnancies was about two, the range one to three, and the number of live
births, same, two, with a range of zero to three.
And so these are the results for the primary outcomes,
which are the clinical accuracy for the SO1
sub protocol. First, for a CIN
3 or greater, the top part of this
diagram shows the sensitivity for self-collection
vaginal samples,
and you can see it's 89.2% for CIN 3.
For clinician-collected samples, it's 96.9.
And then when you look at the relative sensitivity between those
for CIN 3,
comparing a self-collection versus clinician collection, you can see the
relative sensitivity is 92.92.
For CIN 2, the sensitivity for a vaginal
collection is 83.7, and for a clinician
collection, 90.7, and the relative sensitivity,
.92. So in summary, the vaginal
collection is slightly lower than clinician
collection, but the relative sensitivity is quite high, over
92%. And neither of these reached a statistically
significant difference between self-collection and clinician
collection for either CIN 3 or 2.
In the next slide, this shows the main
outcome of positive percent
agreement between self-collection vaginal samples and clinician
collection. First, for the overall
high-risk HPV, the positive percent agreement is
quite high, 92%.
And for HPV 16 on its own, 94, for
16 or 18, 89, and then for the
other 12 HPV subtypes,
89.5. So overall, when
we look back at that meta-analysis that was conducted by the
NCI, we
can see that those estimates in the meta-analyses, in
the pooled meta-analysis,
mirror and are actually exceeded by the data that we're
presenting here in the SHIP trial.
They're comparable to that meta-analysis.
So, kudos to the NCI team for
that.So that data was submitted to the FDA, as
you heard, and on April 8th, the FDA issued its
approval, the first US pre-market approval
for any HPV testing assay to
BD, now Waters Corporation, for its
OncoClarity HPV assay and self-collection assay.
And you may have seen in the Cancer Letter the announcement of
that approval, which was a really exciting
day. And so next steps for
the SHIP trial
is to continue to wrap up the SHIP trial itself.
As you heard, Abbott is one of the four sub-protocols that's still
enrolling.
But importantly, to
get to the third key activity, which is all about dissemination
and implementation of this wonderful,
exciting new technology to reduce the burden of cervical
cancer. And on our next talk, we'll hear all about that, and so I'm really
excited to hear Dr. Montealegre's talk about that.
So this is a map of where HPV
testing is being used.
I know Dr. Kramer showed you about the HPV
vaccine. I wanted to show you a similar map of screening.
And in the green is HPV-based screening, but in the orange is
where HPV self-testing is being
conducted. And with this new data and additional data to come from
the SHIP trial, we may see more orange spots throughout the
world so that we can increase rates of cervical cancer
screening throughout the world.
As I begin to end, I want to show you two more slides.
The first is just to summarize and some of the lessons learned from
the NCI SHIP trial. So the Last Mile Initiative, as you
heard, really focused on generating FDA-grade
clinical evidence, not basic discovery,
to address a critical public health gap.
This initiative, which involved, as you heard, the NCI, the FDA,
academic centers, industry partners, and of course, our patients,
was really brought them all together from the very
beginning to align the scientific questions around the
regulatory expectations,
rather than doing the trials and then retrofitting
those results to meet regulatory
expectations. So really wonderful, visionary way of
doing this. And then by using the common protocol and the
shared endpoints to evaluate multiple industry assays and
collection devices, the SHIP trial not only accelerated the
validation without privileging any particular
single industry partner or vendor and avoided
repetitive siloed studies while
protecting and preserving independent product review.
And finally, it maximized efficiency, and when you maximize efficiency,
you often lower cost. The outcomes of the trial not
only focused on the laboratory performance, but importantly on the
real-world accessibility, usability, uptake,
and those data are forthcoming. So hopefully when we
finish our Abbott enrollment, we can pool that data and present that at a
future conference. And then the platform trial
infrastructure, as you heard me say, will be now utilized to
shift towards what is going to be the next barriers to get
in the way of increasing the uptake of this technology.
And it's going to be all about dissemination and
implementation. And that's really the final
activity that I showed you the Last Mile Initiative is going to focus
on.
And then finally,
this mission-driven initiative generated
very generalizable insights and approaches that I think could be
used and applied to other public health problems.
And so I look forward to any thoughts that you might have on that.
And I want to end by saying that I was honored to
be part of the SHIP trial. And if anybody here is part of that study and
research, I would love them to also receive the credit today,
and including Dr. John Schiller, who is here in the audience, because we
are really up here standing on their shoulders,
these incredible luminaries who have really paved the
way for us to make so much important impact
in reducing this disease. And for anyone who's out there who's a
trainee, my hope is that this arrow will continue to move
forward as you become part of this story to
eliminate cervical cancer.
And lastly, I just want to say thank you, especially to the patients that
participated in this study for sharing their valuable
input and time with us so that we could learn
so much from them. And to the many people at NCI
who have worked on this study, and to
our industry colleagues,
Leidos, and everyone involved. So with that, I will end,
and I will introduce our last speaker, Dr.
Jane Montealegre. Thank you for your attention.
Good morning, everyone.
Oops, sorry. I think I went too fast. Okay.
So I'm going to talk about
HPV self-sampling in safety net and low resource settings.
And thank you so much, Dr. Guerra, for setting this up so nicely in the context of
where this research has been taking place amidst all of the regulatory
and policy work, and then the SHIP trial,
especially, which has been key to getting this approved in
the United States.
I work for the University of Texas MD Anderson Cancer Center.
I have grant support from NIH and from
ourTexas Cancer Prevention and Research Institute.
And then we have received some self-collection kits and testing for
uninsured federally qualified health center patients from what is now
Waters Advanced Diagnostics, previously made by
BD for the Onclarity test.
I'm going to do sort of a whirlwind tour and primer into self-collection in the
US, and I'm going to focus the work on safety nets, which
I firmly believe, and I hope to convince you, is really where we need to be
focusing our attention
in terms of implementation.
So just as background and context, and a lot of this Dr.
Gera talked about, and Dr. Kramer as well, so I won't dwell
on too long. But I want to just mention that this is really
unprecedented. As you all know, you all are cancer researchers, but this is
an actual opportunity to eliminate a cancer for the first time ever,
because we have a safe and effective vaccine, like Dr.
Kramer talked about. We have
screening that is extremely sensitive and
specific, as Dr. Gera talked about.
And we also have all the tools we need to treat precancerous
lesions so that we can keep them from advancing to cancer.
And because of this, I think this is the boldest thing that...
I am so inspired, but in 2020, the WHO came out with
what is the Global Elimination Strategy to eliminate
cervical cancer as a public health problem
in the next 100 years.
And we're going to get there
by achieving 90% vaccination
amongst, especially early in life,
70% screening of women and other people with a cervix
at least a couple times in their life with a high-precision test, and by
treating 90% of those with pre-cancer, cancer,
and of course, all of the survivorship services that are also key to
making sure that we can also do away with some of the stigma
and other aspects that really inhibit the other two
pillars.
And we need to accomplish all of this. Sorry, I should have said this.
We have to accomplish this by 2030.
Otherwise, our math kind of gets a little bit out.
And so
I see this as sort of a race, and I am known for being very impatient.
In fact, Dr.
Vick once said that I like to leapfrog over
certain steps, and maybe that is the case, but I think, every year,
we have thousands and thousands and thousands of people die from an
absolutely needless cancer. So yes, we need to start doing this
implementation work
to get it out into the trenches, like Dr.
Pasket said yesterday in some comments.
This really is about getting it out into the trenches.
So I'm going to focus on the United States a little bit because we're at
AACR.
And while most of the cancers do occur in low and
middle-income countries, I do want to say that some of the pockets in the United
States do more
so resemble what we see in low and middle-income countries
than we think we see for the US as a whole.
So we need to not forget that there are pockets
of... And these are extreme disparities that we see in the United
States.
So when we think about the United States, we are actually pretty close to
elimination. We actually, probably by
2045 or so, would be able to achieve
elimination if we continue with our status quo.
And again, I'm going to sort of talk about my impatience, but this is
not acceptable. We can actually accelerate the
timeline to elimination by 10 to 13 years
if we scale up screening to 90%.
So this should not be something that we see as optional.
10 to 13 years with a mortality rate of 3,000
per year is way too many lives
not being saved because of our inadequacy in
getting this out into the trenches.
So, as Dr. Gera
pointed out, we want to be scaling up screening.
We know we have to scale up screening to 90%.
Unfortunately, that is not the current trend.
Since the 2000s, after we
achieved that all-time high in our screening coverage, we've actually seen a
very steady decline in cervical cancer screening
coverage nationally, so the whole population at large,
with more and more people with a cervix being past due or
not up to date with their screening.
And again,
averages always mask the heterogeneity that exists
beneath. And I really want to point out that the disparities are
quite profound, and this is probably still an
underestimate. But we do see much higher rates of people being
due or past due for screening among racial and ethnic minoritized
populations, immigrant populations,
rural populations, and in particular,
the uninsured and people with
low access to healthcare and living in poverty.
The barriers are complex and multifactorial. Dr.
Gera went into many of them, but I want to say that
there are barriers that are specific to provider-performed
screening,
like the vast amount of people who find this entirely
unacceptable, embarrassing, and uncomfortable to have a pelvic exam.
But also, I think probably an
under-recognized sexual trauma and
under-recognized
or unrecognized
impact of sexual dysphoria and whatnot that exists
in the population. But this is really much exacerbated
by the fact that we have a huge proportion of our
population that faces just exorbitant barriers to
basicprimary care and women's care.
This is the big thing. There are just, in fact, many people who
cannot get in to see their provider due to myriad issues around
transportation, and time, and lack of insurance, and
not having a provider anywhere nearby in the case of many
of the areas that Dr.
Pasket works in. And so I think the reason why we cannot
get stuck here
is because we are in the midst of a big paradigm shift
in terms of how we can do screening.
And the Pap test was brilliant.
I think Dr. Guerra really pointed out that for the first few decades
after this was implemented broadly in the United States, we saw
what was probably one of the biggest success stories in public health
policy and practice ever, right? We saw this massive
decline in incidence and mortality from cervical cancer.
And then things just got stagnant, and we've been stagnant for about
20 years now.
At the same time, we were starting to learn more about the etiology.
Thanks to all the amazing work that so many of you all do in really
the basic sciences, but really understanding HPV and how it causes
cancer. And we first integrated that into our screening
procedures and guidelines with co-testing.
So we did a Pap test with a co-test. But lately what we've been really
seeing is that that Pap test probably is
redundant and probably not needed,
given that primary HPV testing by itself is such a good
test. It is sensitive and specific.
And so in 2018, we first saw recommendations
to
use primary HPV testing, so HPV testing alone with
no Pap test. But ever since 2020, we've started to
see
stronger language around using HPV testing alone,
with this saying this is a preferred test.
And some guidelines even saying, it's acceptable
to use the other ones if you can't do primary HPV testing,
but, otherwise not that acceptable.
And we've seen this in all of these guidelines here.
And so Dr. Guerra pointed this out, but I'll just quickly review that we
have so much evidence from around the world.
We're talking about self-collection here in the United States now.
I think we do need to mention, and I think thank you for demonstrating
that map. There are many countries that have been using this for 20 plus years,
and many countries where self-collection is already part of their national
screening programs and is really being used to reach
the broader and the entire
population. But just to review, we know that
self-collected HPV testing is more sensitive
than cytology alone. It has comparable
sensitivity for detecting high-grade disease compared
to co-testing, but can be done with fewer
colposcopies. So if we're thinking about cost and needless burden on
patients in terms of economic toxicity and
time and
discomfort and potentially trauma, that's a big thing to consider.
And we, like Dr. Guerra showed, and I think the SHIP trial
has really, really demonstrated this, is we have comparable sensitivity
and high agreement between clinician and
self-collected samples.
So what we've seen is we've had broad approval for
self-collection. In May 2024, three different assays were approved
for
use in healthcare settings. So this has to be under some
sort of healthcare provider in some sort of healthcare setting, and I think this
was very wise by the FDA because screening is not a
test, screening is a process, and we
cannot unleash this powerful tool into the
population without having the means and ways to get all
of the people who have a positive test in for the next
steps. Otherwise, this is absolutely pointless.
And so in a healthcare setting was the first rollout.
We had some limited approval of a home-based device
earlier in July 2025,
but not in terms of implementation,
wasn't really able to,
I think, have as much of an impact. April 2026,
as part of the NCI's Last Mile Initiative and the
SHIP trial that provided the evidence for FDA approval, we have our
first assay and kit that can be used at home
or in an unsupervised setting, is probably the better way to say it.
At home,
AKA, you don't have to be in a clinical
office. And then along the way, and Dr.
Guerra talked about this, but we've seen the guidelines already start to endorse
self-collection, including the ACS's guidelines.
The ASCCP, which really dictates how we manage cervical
cancer, pre-cancers, and cervical cancer screening results in the
United States, have also integrated it.
And I think enormously of importance has been
HRSA
in their Women's Preventive Services guidelines, in lieu
of the US Preventative Services Task Force guidelines, which are in this
indefinite draft state until
hopefully not forever, but they're in this indefinite draft
state. But HRSA was able to step up and really give the
green light for self-collection, which just has huge
repercussions for safety nets, which I will talk about next.
So why is this so important, and why is this such a big deal, and why are we
talking about it at AACR? Thank you, Dr.
Pasket, for getting this on the schedule. Thank you, Dr.
Guerra, for
organizing this session. This is a really big deal because
it actually gives us the final opportunity to expand
access and increase screening participation.
So you all recall from Epidemiology 101,
impact equals efficacy times reach.
And we can make very marginal... improvements, and this is
from Dr. Wetter, who presented yesterday, and I loved it, so I'm stealing this from
him. But we can continue to make marginal improvements in our
efficacy, and it's not going to make that much of a difference.
The bang for our buck now is reach. And so this is
extremely important. We know from the global literature that
we see massive improvement in participation among
under-screened individuals when we offer them the opportunity for
self-collection. This has been done in myriad ways
in European countries and more of the higher resource countries in
some trials, including
one that I conducted in our safety net system that I'll talk about next.
Mailed kits can be sent to people's homes.
They result in a 2.5-fold participation in screening.
Door-to-door with community health workers who go to people's houses,
twofold participation, reaching almost 90 or above
90% in getting those people into screening if you take the time to go to their
house and offer them this. Offering in a clinic is very still
limited in our global knowledge
because, outside of the US, that's not how healthcare is
done. So these data are going to start trickling in now that we have
this in the United States, but we also do have some limited evidence for
twofold participation.
So
these are the results from
this huge meta-analysis
first conducted by Arbin, I think in 2018, replicated in
2022 by Stephanie Costa,
and I think it will be republished again very soon to reflect all the new
trials that are coming down the line.
But in terms of the US, I'm just going to quickly review where we've been
over the last several years.
The HOME trial was done in Kaiser Northwest and sent kits
to people's homes if they were under-screened.
Fifty percent
higher screening participation.
The PRESTESS trial, which is a trial that my group conducted in Harris Health
System, again, sent kits to people's home.
But now we started to focus on implementation strategies and workflow
integration, and what does this look like in the real world in an actual
setting where we stand to benefit a lot, safety net settings.
Again, 2 to 2.5-fold higher screening, particularly
because we had a huge patient navigation component to this, which is
key. The STEP trial, again, showing
implementation strategies matter a lot.
The test matters a little bit. How you implement it
matters a lot.
Step two,
how this gets
integrated into clinical workflows. This matters a lot.
Dr. Paskett's APALACHA trial, looking at
underserved women in more rural settings.
Implementation matters a lot. My Body My Test,
again, looking at this equity and underserved populations.
Implementation matters a lot.
So implementation matters a lot, and I'm going to demonstrate that
self-collection will be particularly impactful if we are
able to implement it broadly and widely in safety
net health settings. And this includes county safety net systems,
federally qualified health centers,
FQHC lookalikes,
the Ryan White clinics, all of the safety net that
we think of when people do not otherwise have
access to care. And the reason for this is that we know that
safety nets,
and FQHCs in particular, provide services to populations that are
already disproportionately burdened by cervical cancer: rural
populations, racial-ethnic minoritized populations, people living
with low SES, and those who are uninsured.
And I had the privilege of working with Dr.
Tricia Ambry, who's at
MUSC, and just doing some really great studies
based on national data to show the impact of why we want to
look at safety nets. And safety nets, and particularly
FQHCs, serve over 30,000 people, and the coverage of
cervical cancer screening is actually quite low.
Fifty-five percent is the average, but some of the clinics that I
work with, some of the FQHCs I work with, we're looking at 22% coverage,
30% coverage. This is the real world.
This is the real world. This is why we need to leapfrog some
of these things and really get implementation out there.
But in this study, Dr. Ambry really demonstrate that if we looked at
the under-screened population in the United States, a huge part of
that, and this is looking at the orange is getting to
everybody who's under-screened and eligible for cervical cancer screening.
Eligible on the left, under-screened on the right.
And just showing how many of those people are receiving
care in federally qualified health centers.
And this is by all sorts of categories
of disparities, racial, ethnic, minoritized, uninsured, publicly insured,
poverty, rural.
So this is a really big deal, and it actually gives us, for the first
time, I think, some sort of roadmap as to how we can actually go
about eliminating disparities.
And I think, so it really is talking about concerted effort on the places where we
know we can reach the under-screened.
So that's really been the point of my whole life's work,
basically.
So
our PRESTESS trial was a pragmatic trial that we conducted in
our county health system in Texas, in Houston,
starting right as the pandemic was just being declared in
2020. But we enrolled 2,474 under-screened or
unscreened patients who were identified by the EHR, and we randomized them to
usual care, "Hey, you're past due.
It's important that you get screened.
Let me help you make an appointment."
OrSame exact same script. In addition, I'm going to send you a
kit,
um, that you'll receive in the mail and you can use this in your house.
And here, let me tell you why it's a great thing."
And then that third arm, again, really the power of navigation.
Same script,
uh, additionally sending out that mailed kit, but also following up, uh,
three weeks later, uh, to answer questions,
um, concerns, you name it, um, related
with the patient navigator. Um, and the results of this I think really,
again, show the power of focusing on safety nets.
These rates of 47%, 41% are
about twice of what we saw in higher resource settings in
the European trials, twice as what we saw in the
Kaiser Northwest trials. Yes, there was patient navigation.
It was a little bit more intense, but I think also we have a population for
whom standard of care just is not an option,
period. It's not an option. Um,
so is this cost-effective? Yes. We know from the home
trial that it is cost-effective. We know from
the My Body My Test that it's cost-effective.
We're working on our PRECIS data now.
Um,
but I think the key findings from the cost-effectiveness
analyses are very clear. Cost-effectiveness is highly
sensitive to how we implement.
We can do mail, we can do vert opt-in, we can do navigation.
We can have follow-up systems. What we do and how it's designed
matters a lot, and this has to be done in a way that's feasible
and compatible and appropriate and acceptable for both
the patient population of safety nets, but
also within the whole context of how they provide care.
The FQHCs, they have brilliant ideas of how to do this.
Let's take a step back, um, from our,
um,
we know it all kind of science way of doing things and ask them, "What does
this look like in your setting?" And we learned a lot this way.
Um, we also know that we can increase cost-effectiveness if we can make
sure that the kit return rates increase, and of course, that we
have follow-up for those who are HPV positive, um,
because again, otherwise, this is all pointless.
Um,
so I've been working a lot in federally qualified health centers, and I'll wrap
up pretty soon so we can have time for questions.
Um, it is probably very unlikely that the trials that we have done
at home, uh, Appalachia, the
PRECIS trial where we do a sort of a send out to all will be
feasible for, um, federally qualified health centers, which are
really, it's down to the dime in terms of the money
that they have, unfortunately. Um, so without getting into larger
policy fixes for that, I'll say we need to be
creative. Um, other strategies are going to be feasible
for them. Um, and we also know, we've done some, um, analysis
again with Dr. Ambrey, um, looking at all the opportunities that
under-screened people have,
whether they interface with the health system.
And this myth that people who are under-screened never come
in for anything is entirely a myth.
They actually come in quite often.
They actually come in quite a bit for, um,
birth control, for high blood pressure, for
diabetes, for children's sick visits.
So there are ample opportunities to interface with these, um,
individuals, and we need to start capitalizing and thinking about
creative ways where we can, um, opportunistically screen them.
Um, with all the things that we have available in terms of FDA approval and
regulatory, um, and sorry, and guidelines, this is
just a sort of a flavor of what this could look like.
But we can
offer this in the clinic when people are coming in for their regular adult medicine
visits. Um, I'll talk about some work we're doing there.
This could be a telehealth visit with come in and pick it up.
This could be a telehealth visit with I'll send it out to you.
Um, there can be outreach events, um, again, with on-site
collection. Um, and now, as of a few weeks ago, that can
also be taken home. So lots of different options.
Um, we're working, um, and several people are working on very
pragmatic trials, um, and implementation
studies. Uh, and I think what has been really key here
is, um, really recognizing again that federally
qualified health centers and safety net centers
have a really good sense of what works, and they know their populations really
well. Um, and so really
learning and co-creating what those implementation strategies look like
is really key because they know their populations.
They know, you know, what the best way to do this is.
So we've been
doing a lot of partnering and a lot of co-creating lately,
um, both in, um, community settings with, uh, community health
workers, as in the Prevencion en Sus Manos trial.
Um, we have, um, a couple of, uh, studies in,
uh, safety net health systems, including Harris Health System, our county net
system, as well as several federally qualified health centers, and
really excited to have just received funding for, um, another
implementation, uh, study in a
clinic for the unhoused population in Houston. So lots of things forthcoming.
Um,
we need to get this out again to FQHCs and safety
nets quick. Um, we've been doing a lot of work in trying to
disseminate this work. American Cancer Society has been fantastic.
The National Roundtable, um, has really worked with us to put
together several regional and national webinars just so that we can explain
and kind of
break down like the nitty gritties of how you do this and how you could go about
doing this in your setting. Um, we just published,
um, this self collection implementation guide.
Which again-Nitty-gritty, break it down, make it really
easy. This should not be rocket science, and it's not.
And so we really need to make sure that FQHCs and other safety nets can do it.
Again, and finally, I think this is my last slide, screening is
not a test. It's a process. And so,
all of this work is great and whatnot, but we cannot do
it in isolation. We have to do it with the capacity
building and the network building around making
sure that we have follow-up for all the patients and all of
the individuals who come in from the community who are going to need
follow-up for their abnormal screening test results.
This can either look like in-house or through referral
networks. Patient navigation, Dr.
Paskett, again, I keep on pointing to you, but this is so
important. We need patient navigation to make sure that people can follow up.
And we really need to eliminate the economic burden of
those follow-up tests. And I think, and I'm hopeful that HRSA's
Women's Preventative Services
guidelines and new rules will help take care of that.
It states that screening needs to be covered without a copay,
as do all of the follow-up steps that fall within that
screening continuum. So fingers crossed.
This actually yeah, I know. It's not.
It's never that easy. And those who have the privilege
of Medicaid, it's a privilege.
It's not
a right. And it's not the reality for a lot
of people. And coming from Texas, it's not a reality for a
bunch of people. So this is still important and
probably the big things we need to be looking out at.
So just in conclusion, self-collection is here at last.
It's going to
have its greatest impact if we can implement it in safety
nets that serve the populations with the highest burden of
disease. Implementation strategies matter far more
than the test.
We don't need to keep on refining this
indefinitely and creating highly,
whatever. It's not what we really need to focus on reach.
And so the next frontier is really going to be about optimizing how
we implement and how we scale this up to ensure that
all safety net systems in the United States, and of course, globally as
well,
really have the option of providing this to the
populations they serve.
And with that, thank you so much.
Thank you for two wonderful
speakers on helping us really understand where we are with
the latest data, and congratulations on all your wonderful work.
I would like to invite members of the audience to please ask any
questions
while the members are...
I invite our panelists to ask questions.
You sure may.
Is it on?
So I very much live on the vaccination side, so
I'm always so excited to learn about screening.
I noticed two things that I wanted to follow up, Jane, on your
last point, which is, self-sampling,
I think we've known about it for a long time.
It's great that trials have been done that have got getting us to a regulatory
process. But I'm actually surprised,
from my understanding of the published literature, we can have women diagnosed with
CIN 3 in Latin America, and 10% go on to treatment.
And to your point, that we're all
saying it's not the
swab, it's not how you put the swab in. It's not the test.
It is
truncating the pre-cancer, so they don't go on to cancer.
So where is the research on those
pathways? How do we get the
people treated?
So that's one question. And then another point is,
in the table of the meta-analysis, you focused on the
relative risks that showed a twofold increase in the risk,
it's not a risk, in the
participation with the self-collected swab.
But one of the things I love about clinical trials is the control
arm. And what you look in the door-to-door, the
50%, it was a twofold risk, but the absolute
differences were unbelievable. So not just
multiplying out, like, oh, it's two times better.
But first of all, on the door-to-door, even without self-collection, it was a 50%
participation rate, and then you had a twofold on that.
So how do we pay attention in an
implementation science setting to
if that's where the bang for the buck is?
So those were my questions. How do we get the
research into the process part, not just step
one? And when you have data that shows, or
meta-analytic data that shows that
getting door-to-door is the way to go, how do we do that?
Thank you.
Great questions. Go ahead, Jane.
Goodness. I'm probably not the right person to say this. I'm going to point to Dr.
Paskett.
We need research in implementation.
I think that is the bottom line. I think there's recognition of this.
We now have a discipline called
implementation science that's being recognized, and I think there's recognition
that context matters. There's recognition that
what is done in one setting is not
necessarily translatable to others, that we do need to do setting-specific
research,
and that how we develop these strategies is important, and we have to be
done with the communities we serve. I think there's recognition of that.
I don't think we're there in terms of
really the funding or sort of the
recognition of the science as
being equal or as important as some of the other
research that does take precedence.
SoI'm hopeful.
Yeah. But that's the long answer to that. But we knew.
I think so that's the first thing. The second thing is, for
the follow-up, yeah, I think this is really key. This is so important.
This is the work on navigation and digital navigation,
in-person navigation, telephone navigation, other ways that
we can ensure follow-up,
capacity building within local community health
centers so that they don't have to refer people
80 miles away or 200 miles away to get a
colposcopy and a LEAP. There's a
lot of work that needs to be done in this area, and thank you for pointing that out
because I do think that, now that we have the screening tools
available, we do need to start thinking about shifting our attention
for not only how do we get population screened, but how do we make sure that they
get follow-up? And it is not looking that great.
I will say that in our trial, we had patient navigators who spoke
English and Spanish, which is our predominant languages.
Almost 90-some percent of our patient population
is able to speak those two languages, telephone calls,
you name it.
And we still have a pretty big loss to follow-up,
30%. The reality of the matter is that people are scared to show up at
their provider's offices. They don't have the transportation to get
there. They don't have the trust in the system still.
And they don't have the money, exactly.
They don't have the money because we screen, but
then we charge people $800,
$700 to come and get the next procedure.
So yeah, it's a big problem.
Great. Thank you. And I'll just add that we do have
infrastructure in the Breast and Cervical Cancer Early Detection Program.
So in Philadelphia, where I am, we've been talking with them about
this new approval for HPV self-sampling and trying
to change their policies to allow us.
So great questions, and hopefully this is an
evolving answer. Okay, so we have three people at the podium.
May I start with this side? We'll go to that side, and then we'll come back
to this side. Please tell us your name and where you're from before your question.
Hello, I am Abby Eli. I'm a fifth-year PhD candidate
at the University of Alabama at Birmingham, so the south, an
area where cervical cancer is bad.
I was mostly just wondering, all three of you, you've probably heard of the Teal
Wand, the Teal Health system.
Curious to know your thoughts about how that might play into what
you were discussing with
making sure the patients get follow-ups since that's a
patient-started initiative. Like, the patients have to go seek that
kit versus the clinicians have to calling and
mailing it to them. So getting your thoughts on how that might play
into this whole discussion. And then I know you
mentioned the tool
doesn't matter as much, but do you think that there are any avenues for
new screening tools to potentially
help that follow-up thing, like a
point-of-care test or something that can get results
immediately and then put people like they do with, like, a
see-and-treat approach in India with the
VILI or VIA.
Thoughts on that.
Love the questions. And yes, we saw a picture of the Teal Wand
in one of your slides.
My understanding is that it is just a device.
So it is not the assay. They are waiting for, I believe
it's the Roche assay that they have teamed up with.
So even though they have marketing material out there,
it's not
actually ready for prime time. The second thing is, it's going to
be available to people who can pay for a telemedicine visit to
receive this. So already we're starting with who can afford this
or not. And then your next question, you want to take that?
Yeah. I was also going to say, I think
the Teal Wand,
I think the biggest part of it is going to be sort of how do you get that
integrated into workflows because, as Dr.
Guerra said, it is a whole separate
network of providers. And
so I think that is probably the biggest limitation of it, is how do we integrate
that into the places where people are already getting care?
Because we generally just want to do a one-stop shop when we're
getting our care and have it most seamlessly integrated into a net.
So I think there's a lot of potential, and we'll see where this
goes.
I'm so glad you asked about point-of-care testing.
This is my other big passion area, and I think it's so
important.
It's so interesting because I didn't even talk about the lab aspects of this, but
I think we're just now seeing the national
labs
offering the assays that do
self-collection. We've had extreme difficulty getting the
labs to actually send
the
collection devices out. So there's a lot of implementation aspects
just around regular HPV testing. But the truth of the matter
is, it takes a lot of time. And
anybody who works in under-screen populations, and you know this well,
if you're calling a patient back up in 10,
15 days,
the likelihood of getting hold of them is quite
hit or miss.
And
we lose people
not just because they can't get into follow-up, but because we can't get
them the result. We've lost them literally between when they
screened or performed the test and when they get the test result back.
So yeah, point of care testing is a huge area, and
we're excited to be working on this in Mozambique.
In some areas of Texas, we're trying to get this started, and I'm very
hopeful that we'll see a new horizon of
HPV tests available that are able to do what you're talking about with
a screen and treat kind of approach.
Great idea. Let's go to the next question.
Hi, my name is Naomi Sakura. I'm coming from Japan.
Welcome.
So as you know well, because the Japanese government
stopped recommendations receiving the HPV vaccine for
about nine years. So,
because of those times, some of the scientists and the media
spread information that's not based on the science.
Mm.
So I believe when the vaccine is coming and
approved in Japan, the government call it not HPV
vaccine, it's cervical cancer
vaccine. So there are lots of stigma spread.
And also, I'm a patient advocate, so
difficult to
join the campaign because we have to face a
lot of stigma from the society. But now the situation
is a little bit changing. So I have two questions.
One is
how to educate and share the information for
not only girls, but also boys and
some of the LGBTQ community. That is one of
my question. And the secondary is how to
communicate with anti-vaccinated groups.
It's very difficult to discuss about based on the
science. Let me know those two questions.
Those are really great and important points.
Vaccine hesitancy,
misinformation, and I
understand your country has had terrible problems
and stopped HPV vaccination.
So I am no expert on messaging and
communication for HPV vaccinations.
There are organizations such as the HPV Prevention and Control Board
that has entire communication packets,
and they actually do regional meetings and everything for
deploying the messaging. But I think it cannot
be understated how important preparing
prior to the implementation of
vaccination, like normalizing the conversations around
HPV vaccination. And you raise an interesting point.
When the HPV vaccines, regarding your comment on is it a cancer
vaccine or is it an HPV vaccine? Cervical cancer, and I think,
when these vaccines first came out, some companies went the
path of saying, "This is a cervical cancer vaccine," but in fact, it is a
pan HPV vaccine.
Almost all anal cancers are caused by HPV,
so if you vaccinate, you will prevent the overwhelming majority.
In countries with high HPV-driven oropharynx
cancer, you will prevent those. These other cancers, 16
is the main player. So I understand your point about making it about
cancer instead of an STI. But at the same
time, it's a
vaccine that prevents against six types of cancers.
If we said it was breast, prostate, and four others, people would be running
for it. So, yeah. But all your points are well-made.
There are resources out there. I can talk more a little bit if that's
helpful later.
Thank you. And our last question.
Hi. Thanks. I'm Jennifer Lukesis.
I'm at the National Cancer Institute,
with Dr. Kramer. Hi. I actually have two resources I wanted
to share.
One is that
in the last five years, the NCI partnered with HRSA,
the CDC,
HHS Office of Population Health, and the NCMS joined the
collaboration to create a number of resources
for FQHCs and other HRSA safety net settings of care, and I want to make
sure you have access to all those toolkits.
And if others in the room don't know about those toolkits or where to find them,
you can come see me after. Yes, ma'am.
So, it was really an amazing
collection of materials we put together.
The other thing is I want to encourage
researchers who are in the room who are applying for grants, the National
Institute on Minority Health and Health Disparities
has--
I don't know all of their mechanisms, but please consider
applying there. I'm only just beginning to learn about what they have
available, and I want to make it very clear that they are looking for applications.
So if you have questions about that as well, I'm happy to talk after.
Thank you so much. I recently saw Eliseo Pérez-Stable,
and he said that most people think that institute went away.
No, it is still-
And he assured everybody that it is still awarding grants.
Please apply. Well, thank you for the great questions.
Thank you for your attention, and we really look
forward to engaging with any of you who want to come by and ask a question.
And thank you to anyone from NCI who might be here, partners,
patients that contributed to all this wonderful research.
We thank you, and have a good rest of your meeting. Thank you.